I think the odds of something like this
succeeding it just depends on how well
they support it I personally feel like
the only way that PlayStation is able to
really capitalize is they have to use
their first party studios in different
ways and they've currently done it if
you look at stuff like the Vita you know
their core thing was we're gonna we're
gonna have the people that make our AAA
titles make those games in a portable
different kind of scenario and I think
that was the wrong approach 100 look
look at Nintendo when Nintendo does
stuff they're like look we're gonna make
games that you could easily pause and
you could pick up again in a couple
hours like we're gonna make very easily
portable games Pokemon animal uh
Crossing there's they they have
capitalized a Mario Kart you know they
capitalizing these type of games and to
me the only way it's going to work is if
you know PlayStation goes out to all
their Studios and they're like look